an unexpected reprieve companies are
dependent on Huawei so we're giving them
a little more time to wean themselves
off that means for now US companies will
not face penalties for still doing
business with the Chinese telecom giant
but the reprieve is temporary just 90
days there have been plenty of
discussions with the president and the
president has made clear in his
announcement yesterday that he's very
concerned about more dealings with
Huawei the Trump administration
blacklisted Huawei in May but almost
immediately postponed the punishment
something it's done once again as US
businesses in rural areas scramble to
replace Huawei equipment they depend on
to provide service we're not going to do
business I don't want to do business at
all because it is a national security
threat but Huawei is pushing back on
that claim arguing this decision made at
this particular time is politically
motivated and has nothing to do with
national security these actions violate
the basic principles of free market
competition they are in no one's
interests including US companies but the
Trump administration and US lawmakers
have long accused Huawei of backdoor
espionage resolving those concerns has
made Huawei a bargaining chip in the
ongoing trade war between the United
States and China on Sunday Trump tweeted
discussions to resolve that dispute are
going very well
still Trump's economic advisors signaled
a deal between the world's two largest
economies is far from imminent low level
discussions between the two sides are
expected next week if those deputies
meetings pan out as we hope they will
and we can have a substantive renewal of
negotiations then we are planning to
have China come to the USA and meet with
our principals to continue the
negotiations earlier this month the u.s.
labeled China a currency manipulator for
the first time since 1994 but last week
delayed until December expected tariffs
on products made in China like
toys and electronics the US consumers
like to buy during the busy holiday
shopping season still the u.s. is not
easing up all pressure on China the
Commerce Department has announced its
adding 46 affiliates of Huawei to a list
of companies banned from working with
American businesses as both Democrats
and Republicans in Congress urged the
White House to maintain its hardline
stance
Kimberly Hellcat al Jazeera the White
House